I had a conversation with a good friend
of mine about basically this business
endeavor that he had done and over a
long period of time it ended up not
working out. But in that whole period of
time he never reached out to me once. I
was like why? And what transpired from
his reaction is kind of the point of
this video. I'm going to talk about that
conversation and I think it absolutely
affects so many people and limits their
capacity and why they aren't successful
and some of the underlying reasons. And
at the very end I'll give you kind of a
framework that has helped me through
this year particularly because it's been
a very hard year for me but hopefully it
helps you. The big theme of this though
is that no one cares, just win. Because
until you win, effort always goes
unnoticed. You just have to get used to
it. It's the way of the world. I
remember I asked him, I said, "Hey, do
you mind if I make a piece of content
about this?" He was like, "Sure, but
what about, you know, from our long
conversation, I said, you said this
thing, if I'm going to fail, I'd rather
it be on me." And he's like, "Well, what
what about that was interesting to you?"
He said, "I honestly needed to have that
happen to realize that I can't do it on
my own. Otherwise, it'd be easy to put
that blame on somebody else." And so I
responded with,"How could you put blame
on someone else?" And he said, 'Well,
you know, saying like, "Hey, I failed
because I used someone else's system or
I failed because, you know, so and so
didn't keep their end of the deal or
didn't do their responsibilities or I
failed because they ruined my business
by doing X, Y, and Z." And they're all
basically just like copouts when your
mind gets kind of weak, right? They're
kind of like excuses. But I hate to say
that I've witnessed this happen too many
times. And this is all him saying this.
And I said, "Fault's funny." Because it
just doesn't matter. No one thinks to
themselves like, "Hey, that worked out
really well for him. I wonder whose
fault it is." We only think fault in the
negative. We don't think faults in the
positive. Right? I bring this up to him
and he says, "I have a visceral
understanding of the fact that I need
better systems, you know, better
leverage and better people around me to,
you know, make that next chapter happen
and so I have to stop hiding." In
thinking about this, I was like, no one
asks whose fault it is when it works.
And the reality is that two years from
now, when you think about the
championship Super Bowl game or the
quarterbacks who've who've hit these
records, no one's like, "Hey, you know,
that guy got really good calls from the
ref. Hey, that you know, it was really
raining that day." No one remembers.
They just remember who won. And so, I
think that this is a really interesting
thought line that I wanted to kind of
dive into because the individual in
question did something in the fitness
space. And so, I reached out and I was
like, "Why didn't you ask me for help?"
And this was basically his response was
that he, you know, he didn't he wanted
the failure to be on his own if he was
going to fail. And it was such in
contrast to how I've seen the world that
I thought it was worth making because
for any of you who have this view, I
think it does you a tremendous
disservice because my perspective has
always been it will always be my fault
and no one will care what I got help or
who I got help from. They will just know
whether I won or lost. Period. Period.
And so the reason that the background on
my phone, like I'm so passionate about
this, like the background on my phone is
two words. It's just win. That's it.
It's just win. When I think about that,
it's like no one cares. Just no one
cares. No one's going to ask how many
people did you get help with before you
failed. They just are going to know
whether you failed or not. And I think
it's it's ridiculous to to live life
this way because the real real is that
underneath of this is actually ego. It's
not being able to say, "I don't know.
Please help." And so it means that many
people would rather maintain their egos
and fail than win. And so I think a lot
of beginners are stuck there. They're
actually stuck in their own pride. They
don't reach out for help. They don't
consume content because they think
they're smart enough. And this is
something that's really common amongst
people who identify as being
intelligent. That's actually what's
really interesting. This is why I think
humility is such an important part of of
getting to where you want to go is that
you have to be able to say, "I don't
know." You have to be able to say, "I
failed or I couldn't figure it out." And
so if you can't do that, right, because
you probably maintain some certain aura,
some hidden image to the people around
you of like, "Oh, he's a smart guy or he
was always good at school or whatever
the thing is, like, and then you see
somebody else who was dumb at school all
of a sudden succeed." It's because
usually they're okay being like, "I
don't know. Can somebody help me?" But
if you're the smart one of the people,
you know, then you're not willing to do
that because you have to humble
yourself. The thing is is that the work
has to be done. The learning has to get
learned. The question is what format or
what what mental soup do I need to have
in my head that maximizes the likelihood
that I will learn faster than other
people? And I think humility is one part
of that soup. You have to be humble
enough to listen, to ask. You can learn
anything you want as long as you're
willing to look dumb in front of other
people for an extended period of time. I
think the most underrated money-making
habit is being willing to look stupid.
Because one of the shest ways to never
succeed in life is to avoid looking
dumb. Is to avoid failing. And what's
really interesting about this is that
risk is guaranteed. And so there's this
thing that people have this
misconception, this fallacy about how
life works, which is they want to avoid
risk. But the thing is is that all great
things come with risk. If you put an
idea out there, you risk ridicule. If
you want to fall in love, you risk
rejection. Like if you want to have
intimacy, right, you you risk
vulnerability. Like all of these things
have every wherever there is joy, there
is suffering. And wherever there is
suffering, there's potential for joy.
And so the thing is is that most of
these elements that we want out of life
are double-edged swords. They're two
sides to the same coin. We want one side
without the other. We want the sunny
days without the rainy days, but it's
just weather. And the only way you can
avoid that is by never going outside.
But I think if you never go outside, I
think you miss out on life. And so I
think to the same degree like missing
out on risk is that we have this big
fear of this thing when the reality is
that if you risk nothing you become
nothing. You are nothing because nothing
ventured nothing gained. You're not
going to get what you want by never
risking what you have. And the thing is
is that the things that we have aren't
always material. And I think this is
actually one of the big misconceptions
of people who are starting out is like I
can easily stand here and say you were
the most dangerous in the beginning
because you have nothing to lose. But
the thing is is that almost everyone has
things to lose and most of the things
that they have to lose in the beginning
are in their head and that's why it's so
difficult because what you have to lose
is your social standing. What you have
to lose is looking looking smart in
front of your friends. What you have to
lose is being the the the more
successful one of your medium group or
your low group of friends or the people
who know you or maybe you're the first
one to go to college in your family and
you're the prodigal son or the prodigal
daughter. And so if you go out and fail,
all of a sudden this whole image that
you have, you know, perfectly manicured
and created for your friends and family
gets sha like it vanishes, right? And
your whole identity is wrapped up in
this. But I think that what we have to
do is we have to invest our identity in
different things. I think we have to
invest our identity in our behaviors
rather than what other people believe us
to be. If we think about our identity as
this thing, it's like do we have an
anti-fragile identity? Do we have an
identity that can withstand external
circumstances changing? And I only bring
this up because it was so hard for me.
And also, you know, getting kicked in
the nuts multiple times and losing
everything tends to make you question
like what who am I? And where is my
identity rooted? And so this is
something that I've been thinking a lot
about right now because this year
transparently has been a super hard year
for me. But I I I keep asking myself the
question of like where does my identity
live, right? And this is why I think so
much about behaviors because we try to
say like, you know, you need someone
remember I saw this tweet. It was like,
I don't like it that other people judge
me for what I do or they love me for
what I do rather than loving me for who
I am. And I saw this quote and a lot of
people were liking it and commenting on
it and and then it had a follow-up to
this which was, "Do I love me for what I
do or do I love me for who I am?" And I
think this sounds very pathy and very
rhetorical. It sounds nice, but I think
if you were to ask the question, what is
the difference between who you are and
what you do? you get a very interesting
answer which is it's very hard to
describe who someone is without
describing what they do which is why for
me doing is being then it goes into okay
if doing is being then who I am is what
I do rather than who I am is what other
people think I do and so that means that
when external circumstances get bad what
do I do that is who I am by shifting
that perspective your identity becomes
rooted in the actions that you can
control your identity becomes under your
control and then By extension, the ups
and downs, the emotional roller coaster
that comes with the external status that
people give you for the things you can
do potentially for them or otherwise
then starts to disappear. And I think it
allows you to take the big risks that
you know you need to take. I'll give
this this example, but like when I
started, you know, my gym business to
put us, you know, put this in
perspective, I signed up for a
mastermind of gym owners when I didn't
own a gym. Think of how like how
ridiculous that is. Like I started at a
mastermind. I paid money even though I
didn't have a gym to be with a bunch of
gym owners. Now to me it made complete
sense because I was like well why would
I want to just go make mistakes first
and then go here. I was like I might as
well learn you know where to put the
best location and how much to pay for
rent and you know where to buy my
equipment and what are the best workouts
and how do I find trainers. I was like I
might as well ask them who have 5 10
years each in you know industry
experience and I'll just start day one
10 years ahead. Duh. The thing is is
that that seems so foreign and I don't
know why it seems so foreign. Why would
you not ask for help? And the only
reason I can think of is that you have
an ego. Like I just I don't know the
other reason. Like why would you not ask
for help? I always tried to take the
perspective of like I want to be the big
biggest success story of every mentor of
every person who's ever given me advice
of every vendor I've ever worked with.
And that's fundamentally been my quote
secret is I do everything that someone
else tells me to do to the tea the first
time and then I take what works and then
I toss the rest. And I fundamentally
believe kind of I think um either Theo
said this or Eston I can't remember but
it was like I can learn something from
everyone and in that they are my
superior and so basically everyone is
better than you at something and in that
you can learn from them. And so rather
than having this judgmental perspective
of like I'm better than everyone which
is fundamentally all rooted in ego, you
can always find and this is something
that I've seen of people who are ultra
wealthy that that that you know in my in
my life is that they will actually be
interested in people who are
significantly below them in status
because they will just think how do I
ROI this time and they will just search
for something that this person knows
more about or is better than them at and
then they just hone in on that. And
what's great is that the person who's
kind of below them in status is very
happy to share the thing that they're
really good at. But in that moment,
who's better off at the end? Well, you
can make the argument the person who's
below in status feels great about
themselves because the person who's
above is asking them questions, telling
them it's so interesting. But the person
who leaves with more information than
they started is the one who asked the
questions. Who's the one who humbled
themselves and said, "I don't know
anything about motorcycles. Tell me
about motorcycles." Right? I don't know
how to fix how to fix HVAC fans. Like,
tell me about that. Like, what else am I
going to do? I'm here and we're together
and I can learn from you. But at the end
of the day, one of my favorite
perspectives on on kind of these types
of hardships is it's uh it was actually
on the sword of Gryffindor, but I think
it's so profound is that the the the
dwarves who made it or the goblins who
made it had this kind of spell on it,
which was that it only takes in that
which makes it stronger. And I just love
that as a as a perspective for me on
life, which is that like one, everything
that occurs to us is there is there a
way is there a timeline? Is there a
version of the universe where I get
better from this? And this has just been
very top of mind because 2025 has been
probably the hardest year out of my last
8 years. But I thought to myself like,
well, historically when I have very bad
years, I typically have really good
things that happen afterwards. So what
is the good thing that's going to come
from this? What is the lesson that I
need to learn? What is the friction, you
know, that I'm getting rubbed against
that I need to get reshaped in some way?
And I've had some really interesting
kind of like mental breakthroughs in
terms of what I'm planning to change
about my behavior going forward. But I
will I'll give you this other kind of
mental frame that's helped me through
this, which is when something bad
happens. A lot of the things that are
bad happen only and exclusively in your
mind. And so I'll give you an example.
So let's say let's say you've got
$10,000 saved up. That's your life
savings. Okay? And let's say that you
lose $1,000. That would be pretty
traumatic. That's 10% of everything you
have. Now the question is, what does it
change about what you do? Does it change
the food you eat? Does it change the car
you drive? Does it change where you
live? What does it actually change? It
usually changes absolutely nothing. But
then we choose to feel terrible about it
because because for whatever reason
that's what we choose to do. But the key
word there is choice. We choose that.
Equally we could say I choose to not
feel terrible because it changes nothing
about my life. And so I've used this as
this great framework for like what does
this change about my day-to-day? Does it
change my job? Does it change what I
eat? Does it change who I'm married to?
What does it change about my life? And
most things change absolutely nothing
about your life. And so it's really just
absolutely voluntary suffering that we
choose to subscribe to. We're like, you
know, opt me into that suffering. That
sounds good, right? Of course not. Back
to the risk of what we're willing to do
or willing to take in order to win. Is
that no one will remember that you asked
for help? And you can never expect
someone to invest in you more than you
invest in yourself because at the end of
the day, they will only remember if you
win. And so for me, I always think to
myself, progress is greater than pride.
And the thing is is like there's only
one person's pride that I want, which is
my own. Is that I'm proud of myself.
Because the thing is is that most of the
people in my life will not be here for
the rest of my life. Well, guaranteed
will not be for the rest of my life,
right? Like either they will die or I
will die, but one of us will end. And so
the idea that I'm going to dictate the
the few brief moments I have in this
existence based on someone else's
perception of me feels like a pretty
terrible way to live. And I say this
because it's like, well, obviously we
all know that, but we still do it. And
so it's like what are the mental
frameworks that we have? And so I like
to remind myself that winners write
history. But here's the cool part is
that if you win and when you win, you
get to have a revisionist history of
your own life. Like you can basically
rewrite your own history so that you can
make it whatever you want. Because
what's really really weird and very
trippy that I think about a lot is that
your life only exists in your mind. Like
memory in of itself, like if you start
looking into this the science of memory,
it's wildly
inaccurate. Like we remember our
feelings about how things happen and
like there's the great fruit of the loom
hoax where everyone thinks that there
was like this cornucopia of of fruit on
the tag for Fruit of the Loom, but there
was never a big a bunch of fruit on the
tags for Fruit of the Loom. But we all
have this collective memory around it.
And it just shows how poor our memories
really are. I used to think to myself
that most of the time I'm actually not
going to remember most of the suffering.
And so I'll give you a really really
tactical version of this. So if you've
ever accidentally drank too much and
you're throwing up, right? And you're
like, "This is terrible." I remember
thinking to myself like the first time
that that happened, I was like, you
know, I probably won't remember very
much of this. And I was like, well,
that's kind of refreshing. And so most
of this suffering when I look back on
this will be very, very short in terms
of the memory, even though this may be 4
hours of me wrapped around a toilet. In
thinking about this, it's like a lot of
the suffering that we have to endure, we
actually only remember as a moment, even
though it may have lasted hours and days
and months, there's just these highlight
reels or these reverse highlight
miserable moments that we remember. And
so I think a lot about the concept of
moments because we actually don't
remember most of our lives, which is
like very wild to consider. Like most of
our lives are not recorded and we don't
remember it. It just vanishes into
nothing. All we have are these discrete
moments that we just choose to ascribe
to memory. That means that in the moment
when something's good, I can think to
myself, remember this. Try and demarcate
this moment. And equally opposite, if
something is bad, I can just be like,
you know what, maybe maybe I'm going to
compress this one, right? Like I'm going
to choose to just be like, you know
what, it was it was a brief moment when
it might have been a month of just
absolute misery. And I know that I'm
going to look back on 2025 and just be
like, tough year, right? And then that's
going to be it. But the thing is is like
if I didn't go out this year and ask
other people for help, I might make
2025, 2026, and 2027 all terrible years.
And I would prefer to not have that
happen. What's interesting is that
sometimes the people who have the
hardest, you know, time asking for help
are people who start to become
successful. Maybe some of you in the
beginning were easy to ask for help, but
then then you got the identity of
becoming successful, and then everyone
around you gave you all the accolades,
gave you all the status, and now you're
you're puffed up, so you can't be
perceived as less than. For me, I still
to this day am willing to pay in time,
pay in money, or pay in favors to do
whatever I have to do in order to get
other people to help me because you will
be rewarded far more in life for your
determination than your intelligence.
And the problem is is that determination
just looks like a long string of
failures until it works. You rewarded
for being able to endure the long string
of failures more than you're rewarded
for your intellect at avoiding them.
Because the thing is is that that
suffering is guaranteed. you sticking it
out is not. And so my TLDDR on this is
that you have to incur risk. Period. You
will fail. Period. The only thing that
people remember over the long term and
often and often the only thing you will
remember is whether you won or not. And
so do whatever it takes to win because
you're probably only going to remember
snippets of it and everyone else isn't
even thinking about it to begin with.
With that, have an amazing Tuesday. I'll
catch you guys on the flip side. Bye.